[Music]
welcome back everyone this is going to
be my new harry potter video
they just announced that there's going
to be a harry potter series on hbo
warner brothers is working on so i'll
explain what's going on what they've
said about it so far and where it would
probably fit into the timeline of the
wizarding world in the harry potter
movies
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i will
do episode videos for
when it eventually releases on hbo max
but based on what they've said about
their actual development of the project
i'll explain when i think they'll
actually release episodes
the funny thing is that warner brothers
themselves actually said that they're
starting development but also that there
are no series in development
basically in the same breath which i
think is basically them trying to lie
in cover because they're not ready to
start talking about it yet but you read
between the lines i think it's very
clear that they're definitely developing
harry potter tv series
when it comes to studios commenting
about projects and things like this
especially the really big stuff
you need to learn that people in
hollywood lie
all the time lie about everything
and usually it's the studio putting
pressure on them to lie about it so that
they don't give away any big spoilers or
reveal anything before the studio wants
to reveal things
the hollywood reporter who was reporting
this news are actually very reputable
they're usually very accurate about
stuff like this so if they say there's
smoke then there's definitely a fire
but i think when most of you probably
saw this news this morning you probably
were not surprised
there are so many big shows that are in
development right now big-ip
like the new big budget dc series that
are coming to hbo max
the three new game of thrones prequels
that they announced a while ago
and hbo max has not been doing so well
that's why they have their big 2021
movies planned to release
all of their new movies on hbo max
simultaneously at the same time as they
do in theaters
they want to be able to compete with
netflix all the programming that they
have coming
disney plus and all the big marvel and
star wars series that they have coming
down the pipeline the next few years
so harry potter and the wizarding world
franchise is one of the most popular
things that they own
it was only a matter of time before they
reached into that sorting hat to pull
out some tv shows
they still are doing the fantastic
beasts sequel movies right now there
have been rumors
that after those they may eventually
reboot the original harry potter movies
or bring the original cast back for
direct sequels to the original movies
because every year people ask the
original cast daniel radcliffe
emma watson rupert grint are you going
to come back as the og
team for more new harry potter rupert
grant so far has been the only one who's
like yes
definitely i will totally come back for
more harry potter in the future
daniel radcliffe is kind of on the fence
the way he talks about it he says that
he's totally fine with them completely
rebooting the franchise but then also
maybe someday he'll eventually come back
and do more harry potter but he's not in
a huge rush to do that
and emma watson has also kind of said
similar things like i'm working on a
bunch of other projects so she's not
rushing to come back and do more harry
potter
but based on the timeline of the
fantastic beasts movie right now
if they wind up bringing the cast back
or rebooting the movie franchise
that wouldn't happen for like seven or
eight more years so that's so far off in
the distance that you don't even need to
worry about that right now
which is where all the tv shows come in
that they're developing
there is also that harry potter and the
cursed child stage play which is sort of
like another direction that they've
expanded the universe and is a sequel
series to the original movies so i'll
explain that during this too
but i think all this harry potter
universe movies tv shows makes more
sense when you hear that warner brothers
just named
their own kevin feige person is an
overseer for
all the harry potter franchise related
projects that includes any of the new
movies that they do the fantastic beasts
movies any other prequels or sequel
movies they do in the harry potter
universe
fantastic beasts was really just the
start of that and any new tv projects
that they spin off as well
they haven't officially confirmed
exactly when this first new series would
take place and which characters it would
follow they've only said that they've
just started meeting with people taking
pitches and the strongest concept is
going to win out but i think the idea is
that they wouldn't just reboot the plot
of the original movies straight up so
we're probably not going to see them
cover the events of the main books
if they did that like i said they'd
probably wait for a movie series reboot
in seven or eight years
just reading all the different news
announcements that the outlets are
putting out about this project it sounds
more like they're taking the lord of the
rings approach with it
the past couple of years if you haven't
been following the news amazon and
warner brothers
spent over a billion dollars to get the
rights to the lord of the rings
tv series that's right warner brothers
had the rights to the movies
doing a lord of the rings tv series
apparently way more expensive for them
but because the movies were so good and
still so popular they didn't want to
just redo the plot of the movies with
the tv show so the lord of the rings tv
series is a prequel set during the
second age of middle earth and is going
to follow sauron as he creates the rings
of power
sauron when he looked like this so the
harry potter people at warner brothers
have a billion different prequels to
pick from that they could do
and still tie very closely to the events
of the movies but just given their
restrictions here are my top picks for
what that would be
just starting with the very obvious
story of the founding of hogwarts like
hogwarts year one
it be said almost a thousand years ago
with godric gryffindor salazar slytherin
helga hufflepuff and roryno ravenclaw
coming together putting aside their
differences temporarily at least
to build the school itself and just
follow them in the first years of them
running the school
there's only some of hogwarts early
history that's been well documented but
there's enough canon that they wouldn't
have to just make everything up out of
thin air to contradict later facts
established in the main books
that's usually the danger with any big
prequel series for books that haven't
completely been written yet
they haven't really said much about jk
rowling's involvement since she could
also expand as much of the history
of the universe and characters as they
would need to actually turn something
into a full series
and that's true for any story that they
go with but she's kind of a
controversial figure right now so i
don't know how much
fans want her to be involved with the
material and it's not like a george r
martin situation with the game of
thrones franchise in the prequels that
hbo is currently doing
even though he writes as slowly as
possible and we will probably never see
the full completion of a song of ice and
fire novel series
fingers still crossed for winds of
winter released next year though he
still has a pretty decent relationship
with the fandom and with warner brothers
and hbo brass
and he's very much involved with helping
them plot out the story of the game of
thrones history
for their prequels just to make sure
that they don't mess too much of that
history up
the reason why they created hogwarts in
the first place is because at that time
in history wizards and witches were
being heavily persecuted by society and
they wanted to create a secret place for
them to learn the craft of magic
so they built hogwarts in the scottish
highlands and threw up enchantments
around it to prevent muggles from
discovering it
the four of them worked together for a
little while at least until their
infamous falling out over exactly what
and who they should be teaching at
hogwarts
that's all covered in the backstory that
they give you in the harry potter movies
and books
but it's a really easy slam dunk and
it's set far enough
in history that it would be a lot easier
for them to tell that story they would
run into fewer
issues with contradicting the timeline
and keeping things in continuity than
they would if they did a series in
present day
the next big prequel series that a lot
of the fandom has been talking about for
a long time
is just a straight-up marauder series
about harry's father and his friends
creating the secret club and the
adventures that they have during their
school years in the 1970s
if it wasn't clear or you didn't read
the original books harry potter starts
year one at hogwarts in the early 90s
not the early 2000s the movies kind of
blurred this a little bit shifting
things forward in the timeline
closer to the present day of when the
movies were actually being released in
those early 2000s so that's why some of
the technology that they see in the real
world
seems like early 2000s technology and
not 1990s technology
i think as long as they're consistent
with the time setting of the events of
the original movies anything that they
do with the prequel series will be fine
there have been a lot of people since
the news was announced that have been
asking for a young
severus snape series people have been
fan casting adam driver but i don't know
how up he is for doing a harry potter tv
series
but i do like the idea of a young
severus snape series about his later
time in school in his early years in the
death eaters and then falling in with
the events of how he started working as
a double agent for dumbledore
so day one it would also just be way
easier to do his story than for another
character
in the last really big idea would be for
them to do something with either a
younger voldemort during his school
years and early years after leaving
hogwarts creating the horcruxes looking
for the deathly hallows
like a death eaters series which would
be a darker spin
don't know if they would want to do that
if they want to do something that's a
little more family friendly
or they just do a bigger version of
harry potter in the cursed
child the only thing about cursed child
is that it's one of those more recent jk
rowling's additions to the canon that
fans either
love or they hate because of how it
addresses some of the events of the
original books and movies
it's one of those series that sort of
retells some of the plot of the original
story and changes some things
so it's easy to see why some fans didn't
like that story like why are you messing
with this original story it was already
perfect why do you have to trample on it
if you never saw the cursed child play
or read the story it set 19 years after
the events of the deathly hallows
and harry potter has since become the
head of the department of magical law
enforcement of the ministry of magic
in his younger son named albus severus
potter is getting ready to start his
first year at hogwarts
he was named after dumbledore and snape
it's literally the deathly hallows
ending scene of them showing up at
platform nine and three quarters where
you see all of them
older the older son that they have there
next to him is named james sirius potter
so they just send him off to his first
year at hogwarts and that's where the
events of cursed child play out
the story itself winds up twisting a lot
of the conventions of the original harry
potter books where harry's son
winds up becoming good friends with
draco malfoy's son instead of becoming
enemies his name was scorpius
and then albus severus winds up shocking
everyone when he gets sorted by the hat
into slytherin's house you can imagine
the heart attack that it gave harry
he and scorpius wind up getting into all
kinds of trouble using this special
prototype
super time turner to mess with
historical events in the harry potter
universe
and it winds up crossing over and making
some big changes to the night that
voldemort killed harry's parents
and marked him as the final horcrux so
it's very controversial either way and i
think that warner brothers is going to
try and avoid
altering any of the pre-existing cannon
as much as possible which is why it's
more likely that if they go the prequel
route they'll just steer clear of recent
history
but based on their timeline for
development like they just started
working on the series right now it'd
probably be at least like three years
before we see any kind of footage or a
trailer or they start filming and
casting
i will do another video about it when we
get more concrete details and as long as
the series is good
i will do episode videos for it but
obviously i'll be doing episode videos
for the lord of the rings series on
amazon all the game of thrones prequels
the marvel star wars disney plus series
and all the dc hbo series but everyone
click here for my brand new one division
episode 3 video in marvel easter eggs
and click here for that brand new
godzilla vs kong trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
you